The Joe Rogan experience the cards.
Did you ever have a comedy card?
No,
never had it.
We had a card once to promote a website that I put out to promote my website,
but there was never one for like,
like I'm appearing in this town like with like pointing to the right and the
big.
Someone told me,
what am I coming to you?
Someone told me that my track record is this and then I'll tell you what
somebody told me,
George Carlin said,
but at least I wish I could have said I never had a card.
But I am proud to say if I'm going to be 100 percent honest.
I had one for like a month and then I just didn't like the smell of it.
So I got rid of it.
No tagless comedian.
I was like,
Shit.
I think I saw some other comedian with a car and I'm like,
I should have caught it.
And then I got rid of him.
So now I'm glad because someone said somebody at the.
George Carlin was talking about cards backstage at the comedy magic club and
basically said,
he goes,
you know,
the comedian doesn't have a fucking card,
and then the comedian that had the guard sort of felt like he took them very
quickly over to the truck because he had just gotten cards.
Yeah,
that's.
That was a thing about head shots back in Boston.
Anybody who's any good had the shitty headshot,
they didn't give a fuck about their head and you can see that same,
that same path.
They would talk about it like if you hire a photographer to do your headshot,
you fucking suck on stage.
Would always say that.
That was just such an unspoken.
Are there exceptions?
Yes,
but no.
Mostly that such a great.
Well this something that makes you want to take a picture of yourself and be all
sexy looking.
That's Uber.
Douchey doesn't translate into comedy.
You know,
there's some guys are good ham it up.
Like I remember Kevin Knox had like a really Zany,
like head shot,
but it worked for him because that was like his act,
like he was a wild energetic guy.
What if I talk about how bad that is and I agree with you,
but then you guys pull online.
A picture of me with my shoe is a phone
picture of you.
I like.
Oh,
that with the shoe?
Yeah.
It was like it was a phone.
Nobody did that then?
No,
it was really the first.
I thought it was real for sure.
When I was a kid I was like,
they sat it on TV.
They said it's a big foot.
The guy got a big foot,
but then when you watch it,
like slowed down and then enhanced and then you look at how little detail you're
really seeing.
Like everything's all flush.
Like everything's like bright,
like the leaves and trees.
It's almost white,
like there's no detail at all.
So you pretending that you see all this detail in this monkey suits,
but ignoring the fact that you can't see the fucking trees,
you know,
where's he going?
He's very nonchalant about it too.
It's a girl supposedly.
Oh,
where's she going?
She's going to go get some dicks.
It's often a lot of big floods.
Kind of nonchalant,
like,
oh,
I got spotted,
okay,
I'm off the lunch.
Like,
you know,
there's no real purpose to look at this thing
to me is like there's like some moments where she picks her feet up or it or he,
Bob Hieronymus Bosch and the bottom of the feet.
It's fucking worn.
Big Feet,
big rubber feet like that.
You got to really throw your legs up higher and it's definitely apparent and
that was one of the things that they said that the gate was off.
It was hilarious.
I was talking to this expert when I was doing the Scifi show who was arguing to
death with me about this.
He was like the average gait of a human being.
It's not like it was like nine degrees,
but the big foot is like 25 degrees.
I go,
oh,
you mean he would have had to do this?
And then I started walking around like big flood.
I'm like,
what the fuck man?
Like you're supposed to be a scientist.
Like you're crazy.
That's a guy in a suit.
But it's like a,
it's a crypto zoological.
Jesus.
Like you're not supposed to fuck with the Patterson Gimlin footage.
They all believe it.
I have not talked to one of those dudes who are like crazy big foot fanatics who
think it's a hoax.
Fucking believe I got so high once,
I believe for 15 whole minutes.
I thought for a second and we were at the Ice House and we're doing a comedy
show and then we start talking shit and we played the footage and we were so
baked.
I was looking at the video and I was like,
oh my God,
what if it's real and I'm just an asshole?
What if it's real?
And this whole time I've been denying like the greatest discovery in crypto
zoological history and I'm just being a dick,
but then I sobered up.
Well,
you know,
it's like wanting to,
believe in real monsters.
I mean,
the lochness monster is another one.
every culture has won.
The lochness monster has got to be the biggest pussy of all time because he
never kills anybody.
How do you get to be a monster?
It's icon,
a whale,
and may just become missing people because they're taken under the water.
Your opinion though,
at your expert opinion,
what is that?
What's what?
What are we looking at for the paterson footage?
Just for the record,
what are we looking at man in a suit?
A man in a suit?
Yeah,
hundred percent,
right?
Ninety nine percent.
Jesus Christ.
He's a fucking special effects expert.
And these knuckleheads like of ways that the legs move that you just can't do
what the human frame they want to convince themselves so bad that a con man
figured out how to find bigfoot and did it in like a day.
Lighting is your new book and um,
what it's a,
there's a really important thing that you,
uh,
you bring up.
It's not on the front part of this.
I've read it online somewhere that you can avoid a lot of problems in your life.
Yeah.
Simply by not lying.
Almost.
Almost all of them.
Of all the ones that are avoidable.
Yeah.
When you just look at how people screw up their lives line is.
If it's not the reason,
it's the thing that enabled the other reason.
I mean people complicate their lives massively by a willingness to deceive
others and this has many features to it.
One is just there,
all the things you can do based on the cover that lies provide that you
shouldn't be doing because they're not good for you and now,
and everyone would hate you if they knew you were doing them or your,
you know,
your wife would leave you or whatever,
whatever it is.
And so the law,
the lies,
lies create a space in which you can let your life run off the whale,
run off the rails,
whether it's becoming an addict or with a or,
or,
um,
uh,
you know,
perpetrating financial frauds or whatever it is.
Uh,
uh,
but there's,
there's also this component where you don't actually,
you never actually discover who you are in social space if you always leave
yourself this out of line.
So it's like you never discovered that if you keep canceling plans with people
and just tell this white lie that you're too busy or you're not feeling well,
or is that you never have to confront the fact that these are people you
actually don't want to see people in your life who want to go out to dinner with
you.
You don't want to see them and you're never having to confront that because you
have this out that you're just gonna lie.
You know?
And,
and there's just,
if you want,
there's actually no change in a person's life that I think is more important in
terms of getting your life straight,
your,
your to ship straight.
You're just getting into the future without screwing it up for yourself.
There's no more important change than,
than a commitment to being honest in,
in whatever the situation is.
That presents itself.
When I was a freshman at Stanford,
I took a course with a professor who actually interview in the back of the book.
I'm Ronald Howard,
who is a really brilliant guy who started a whole academic field called decision
analysis and the sixties,
and it's,
it's a,
it's a mechanism which
allows someone to make as rational decision as possible by putting all of their
information about a topic into,
into a,
essentially a calculation.
Um,
it's got nothing to do with,
with,
uh,
with line or honesty,
but he's a,
he's a,
a,
a professor in the engineering economic systems department's efforts and he as
kind of a sideline to his,
his academic work was teaching these,
these courses on ethics and one course was just on the question whether it's
ever ethical to lie.
And so as a freshman I was just sort of put in the machine of this course and
came out the other side,
convinced that in virtually any situation,
apart from like a self defense situation where you would,
where things have really broken down and you're not in the presence of someone
who you're going to collaborate with line is just unacceptable.
It's just not,
it's not how I want to live.
It's not how anyone should want to live.
If they look at it closely enough.